تحت عنوان وطن اسمه فيروز اكثر من 35
كاتبا عربيا اجتمعوا على صفحات مجلد واحد
ليكتب كل منهم عن فيروز من زاويه اختصاصه
ومن مكانه الجغرافي ووفقا لرؤيته الذاتيه
والاكاديميه هذا الاصدار الخاص هو من
انتاج مؤسسه الفكر العربي تكريما لفيروز
بمناسبه عيدها 88 يمتاز الكتاب بطابعه
الجاد والانيق وهو مزدان برسومات لفيروز
مستوحاه من صور متداوله
فعلى مدى 350 صفحه من الحجم الكبير ستقرا
التحليلات والمعلومات تصب في اتجاه
التاكيد على ان فيروز ظاهره استثنائيه
وكل ما نستطيع اتجاهها ان نفهم قدرتها على
عبور الزمن واختراق قلوب الناس لتبلغ هذا
الاجماع النادر لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات